you know Jim Cameron has got an
incredible record when you think about
the movies that he's done in water the
Terminator all the fighting all the car
chases all the shooting all the effects
all everything blowing up uh and Aliens
things are blowing up fire always all
over the place I don't nobody's ever
been Hur on a gym car here's another
story I'll tell you quickly and then you
can edit what you want to edit okay so
uh Jim is um I'm I'm working I believe I
was working on the Terminator with him
at some point in the Terminator and he's
working on the set and I I noticed a
difference about him I noticed that he
wasn't his he
wasn't himself and he seemed a little
bit distant as compared to the Jim
camman who's in your face going I want
this and I want that you got it you got
it okay let's roll come is everybody
ready all right let's roll you know he's
there's something that seemed a little
odd about him and uh at one point it was
in the morning I think at one point in
the morning I pulled him said Jim are
you okay are you all right you seem he
goes I'm okay I said are you sure and he
said
well you know Michael I wrote a
script
um uh for
um uh what's the Stallone movie where
he's out in the woods he's Rambo Rambo
ra he wrote he wrote Rambo
too and you know I wrote a scene and I
just heard this morning or last
night
that uh a stunt man was killed doing
that scene that I
wrote and uh I you know I said Jim like
what you know you can't blame yourself
for that but but he felt it he felt it
and so people that think Jim Cameron is
just this like film making you know like
you know he's a he he's a compassionate
caring
person sometimes doesn't have time to
show it but that's a perfect example of
a thing that he was taking um he was
taking it on himself and I said to him
like and and and had to say Jim like you
can't blame yourself for that I'm not
sure that that helped the situation but
he felt it uh well he he he felt what
happened to him and it affected the way
that he was uh uh not performing but the
way that he was uh working the next day
and I I saw it Vis V I knew him well
enough at the time that I